this is a very densely written show
every detail is so important from the
design of the room to the color palette
to the hair to the costume the
emotionality of what our characters are
going through hey look that's my sister
right there i thought it was a very
complex season for bradley her character
didn't just touch on being queer it
touched on family with addiction and how
we all get sucked into that vortex of an
addict's life and ultimately falling
apart because you have no power over
that
we're past it now are we oh my god
that's good to know i didn't know that
we alex don't do this to us we're
finally in a good place one thing that
jen and i discussed we wanted to make
sure chip and alex didn't come across
that they were just like siblings
yelling at each other we wanted to layer
everything with a deep sense of
dedication and love and i think honestly
it's been easy because just find jen to
be so buoyant and she's so alive
we're okay i love the relationship
between chip and alex chip is kind of in
love with her and they each see the
relationship a little differently i
think alex she's getting out beyond her
narcissism enough to understand she's
taken chip for granted and he has always
been there for her
mitch was
which is a human being
karen was so beautiful in that scene
and it spoke beautifully to the moment
too that you are some of the things that
have happened to you in your life you're
not just the one terrible thing he
really does have young children it's
complex we're getting to see in their
eyes in their faces all of the feelings
that they had about mitch and now they
have to reconcile them because he's no
longer there we really see mia spilling
out all of the feelings that she has in
the midst of this grief i think i knew
the real him and that book doesn't get
the real him
an actor is only successful as the
director that she is able to collaborate
with and victoria mahoney who directs
episode 208 is an extraordinary
collaborator that first day i worked
with her
i just felt i'm madly in love i was like
where have you been all of our lives
knows how to speak to actors so
beautifully she was incredible go
filming this episode was such a
whirlwind in an already intense
environment thankfully my character is
always in sneakers but i literally had
to run we were sweating doing that we're
interrupting with some breaking news our
stories are told through our characters
points of view they're complicated as is
life as is human emotion one moment
you're happy one moment you're trying to
figure out where do i fit how do i get
there what do i do
[Music]